what about the egg freezing benefit that
also got a lot of attention Facebook and
Apple give women $20,000 to freeze their
eggs if they want to a lot of critics
say that sends the wrong message work
now family later Facebook's family
planning I mean I I think it's a
fantastic idea it's something that you
know we're virgin what you know want to
steal the IT Randy Randolph attar woman
and and it's interesting somebody said
to me they got make our criticism for it
emma is it what on earth how can anybody
criticize them for doing that for its
woman's choice you know they want to if
they want to carry on working they can
carry working and you know if they if
they haven't managed to find them a man
of their dreams at 35 36 37 38 and you
know it frees the eggs it makes sense
and we don't you know that earlier you
can freeze them the better my child my
daughter's just had two wonderful twins
from from from eggs and they wouldn't
wouldn't be there here today but it
wasn't clear we offer benefits for all
life stages and really generous benefits
we don't just try to follow the market
we try to follow our employees so we
offer you know four months of maternity
and paternity leave if you can take it
anytime in the first year we give you
cash when you have a baby whether you
adopt or you give birth the genesis of
this particular benefit is an
interesting story and one I really learn
from which is that there's a young woman
working at Facebook who had got cancer
and I knew her and she came to me and
said I'm going to go through the
treatment and that means I won't be able
to have children unless I can freeze my
eggs and I can't afford it but our
medical care doesn't cover it she was
coming to me for advice and help and I
talked about it with our you know head
of HR and I said god we should cover
this and then we look to each other me
said well why would we only cover this
for women with cancer why wouldn't we
cover this more broadly and that was
where that then if it came from and we
think it's great